let's talk a little bit about uh double
standards earlier in the show I told you
what the latest polling data was for the
eventual november eighth presidential
campaign this is just the best remember
how for months and months maybe at this
point has been more than a year Donald
Trump rallies were basically Trump
reading polls right he would show up and
this was before he was put on that
teleprompter which was a disaster in of
itself he would show up with stacks of
paper and instead of firing people up
with policy ideas or explanations of how
he's going to make this country great
again he would go up there with reams of
paper and just read polls in a very sort
of weird way but he clearly loved the
polls right he would show up and it's a
you know we're we're up in such and such
we're way ahead here were way ahead
there they can't keep up with us here it
was abundantly clear that polls were
something Donald Trump believed in
something Donald Trump liked and
something Donald Trump trusted but now
he has gone from exclusively believing
in polls as the number one indicator for
how the race is going to now that he's
losing in something like 25 of the last
25 polls versus Hillary Clinton gary
johnson and Jill Stein now all of a
sudden he doesn't really believe polls
any more polls aren't something he's
interested take a look at this clip from
a rally just a couple days ago in
Colorado Springs now even though we're
doing pretty good in the polls I don't
believe the polls anymore I don't
believe I don't believe them and if
there's ten and if there's one or two
bed one sets the only one they show
believe me folks we're doing great if we
keep our spirit and if we go out and win
this is another brexit believe me they
are so worried that's why they become
vicious and hostile and dirty because
they see what's going on yeah everybody
sees exactly what's going on and it's
not believe me folks we're doing great
if you went to a trump rally a year ago
or even six months ago you would get 15
20 or even 30 minutes of just printed
polls which is a really unusual
technique right if you've got this crowd
they've gone through two or three warm
up people getting everybody fired up for
Trump
then Trump comes out with 50 pages of
polls and just starts reading
methodology and polling data to you not
exactly electrifying political speech
for me right I mean maybe maybe the
Trumper's like it he loved polls and
then now all of a sudden he doesn't
really believe the polls it's it's the
same this guy's my best friend so he's
the best to this guy's my enemy and he's
a loser and you can't trust him and in
this case the friend or enemy has become
polling data and by the way you don't
even really need to look six months back
to see the double standard with Donald
Trump a lie is never too far behind he
tweeted this the day before announcing
at this rally that polls don't matter
anymore putting out a tweet uh saying
WOW new polls just came in from CNN
great numbers especially after total
media hit job leading Ohio 48 244 so
even 24 hours before when there was a
poll that was looking good uh it was a
poll Trump wanted to talk about uh a
lots changed since then as we know with
Trump we can't judge Trump for what he
did ten years ago I mean after all he
was a 60 year old man then he was really
still learning about life and coming
into his own uh so it's really no
surprise that even a few days ago he
would have a completely different
position on polling maybe he was egged
on to send that tweet